[Music]
from warner brothers studios in
hollywood it's the conan audiency awards
celebrating excellence in the sitting
and looking arts
here now is your host conan o'brien
thank you thank you very much
welcome to the audiency awards uh for a
night that's important first i need to
dress the part bruce if you don't mind
[Music]
thank you
this is my sexy walk
here it is ladies and gentlemen you've
all dreamed of one day having one the
conan audiency statuette
beautifully crafted
it took six minutes to make this award
and it's highly toxic
let's demon let's begin our first
audiency award is for the best
impression of a celebrity
and the audience he goes to the person
in seat 5d for their impression of nba
commissioner david stern
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
you are david stern aren't you
okay good god
you just lost your award uh
kidding
the next audiency awards also for best
impression of a celebrity in the
audience he goes to person in seat 7j
for their impression of mila jovovich
from the fifth element let's take a look
[Applause]
[Music]
what did you want
oh the award we only have one
it's cable
this next ic
[Applause]
this next audiency award is also for
best impression of a celebrity and the
audience he goes to the person in seat
17m for their impression of our trumpet
player mark pender
[Applause]
why are you puckering your lips at it
okay all right
our next award goes to the person in
seat 4s it's the award for the audience
member who has written over 600 pages of
jonas brothers fan fiction
[Music]
congratulations
next the award for audience member we
borrowed from ellen's
audience over soon
[Applause]
it's only 50 more minutes you can hang
in there
our audience
making those noises
our audience is the most generous in the
world often after the show we find that
people have left little gifts for us
under their seats well we put all those
gifts to good use behold the conan bust
made entirely from your leftover gum
[Applause]
[Music]
a lot of award shows have their own
caddy correspondent to comment on red
carpet fashions well the audiences are
no exception please welcome our own
audiences fashion assassin james
sinclair saint orleans
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
my crappy fashion senses are tingling
let's see our first victim
oh
what a tragedy did you buy that outfit
at j.crew because it's j cruel to make
us look at it
who's next
oh
[Music]
wow great halston's ghost what is that
wow i didn't know they had a men's
warehouse in the ukraine
well no one's gonna like the way you
look hey thanks for coming out though
i'm sure you'd rather be operating a
taffy machine at the 1894 world's fair
bring me my next victim
oh look
it's like a car accident i want to look
away but i can
well well look who's been shopping in
the formal section of urban outfitters
or maybe you're shopping at h m if h m
stands for hideous and make me puke
well i could do this all day but queen
daniel and i are going to have our yum
yums bleached smell you later
[Applause]
[Music]
horrible i hate that guy
you know all the big award shows always
include a respectful and touching
memorial tribute so we too wanted to
remember some audience members who were
sadly not with us today
that's because their church group's bus
broke down just outside of mendocino
here with a musical tribute to those
audience members we lost is miami
beach's fourth hottest recording artist
r o t f l o l wtf
in my dreams i'll see you on that broken
bus so far away but your memories are
close to us
my prayer to god tonight is move that
bus but please move it
oh god won't you please
[Applause]
[Music]
okay to the members of the first
lutheran church we will
miss you
great show tonight
[Applause]